bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne les travaux de la
mission commune d'information du sénat
sur les dispositifs médicaux
implantables les interventions
esthétiques
les sénateurs de la mission auditionne
cet après-midi laure lechertier elle est
responsable du département politique des
produits de santé à la mutualité
française département qu'elle dirige
depuis 2005
je vous rappelle que l'objectif de cette
mission est d'empêcher un nouveau
scandale sanitaire comme celui à des
prothèses pip est pour chantal jouanno
sénatrice ump de paris qui préside cette
mission il faut adapter la loi face à
une société où la place de l'esthétique
a crû de façon exponentielle tout de
suite donc sans plus tarder direction la
salle médicis pour écouter laure
lechertier bon après midi à tous les
aujourd'hui donc nous auditionnons
en ce début d'après midi madame laure
lechertier qui est responsable du
département politique des produits de
santé à la mutualité française et qui
est accompagné de d'une personne qui ce
qui se présentera et j'imagine donc en à
madame
enfin monsieur on a malheureusement vu
une multiplication de scandales et sur
la faire péter bien entendu mais ensuite
sur les prothèses de hanche depuis par
exemple ou tout autre ou d'autres
dispositifs et lors des différentes
auditions que nous avons eues revient
systématiquement des sujets qui je le
sais vous tienne vous tiennent à coeur
des autorisations de mise sur le marché
alors sans doute dans une forme un peu
différente de celle qui existe pour pour
les médicaments mais qui pourrait
concerner les dispositifs médicaux les
plus les plus à risque lors des assises
du médicament vous avez souligné la
nécessité de refondre le marquage ce et
eux de renforcer la matériovigilance que
ce soit en pré marché mais surtout en
poste mise sur le sur le marché et la
traçabilité des dispositifs médicaux qui
pourraient être liés à l'or à leurs
remboursements donc nous souhaitons vous
entendre sur tout c'est sûr toutes ses
propositions parce que vous représentez
une institution qui rassemble près de
600 mutuelles sauf erreur de ma part et
qui protège 38 millions de personnes
dont vous êtes particulièrement
concernés donc nous souhaitons vous
entendre sur ces différentes
propositions
que ce soit sur les dispositifs médicaux
mais aussi si vous avez des idées sur
ces sujets sur les interventions à visée
esthétique puisque il y a un lien entre
les dispositifs médicaux et c'est et ses
interventions mais surtout nous nous
sommes aperçus que c'était un secteur
qui était assez peu régulé dans notre
pays comme dans d'autres comme dans
d'autres pays d'ailleurs avant de
laisser la parole à notre rapporteur
bernard cazeau qui a une série de
questions à vous poser
je souhaitais juste vous informer que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et au public
qu'elle est enregistrée et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat s'il n'y voyait pas d'objection
donc je laisse la parole à monsieur
bernard cazeau bien mesdames messieurs
mes chers collègues je voudrais tout
d'abord vous demandez mais très
brièvement de vous situer dans la vôtre
positionnement dans la mutualité
française située qu'elle aussi pour
certains de nos collègues les rôles et
missions et vous dire les fonctions
cousy occupé pour qu'on situe bien dans
ce domaine tout mais très brièvement
allez-y vous appuyez sur le rouge
ben voilà bonjour messieurs dames
bonjour madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur
tout d'abord je tiens à vous remercier
d'avoir pris de ce temps de la mission
d'information pour recueillir l'avis de
la mutualité française que dont je vais
vous dire quelques mots mais madame la
présidente vous
vous m'avez vous avez dit vous même les
éléments deux chiffres importants que
que j'allais vous signaler mais
effectivement c'est très important
alors aujourd'hui laure lechertier dont
vous avez donné le titre responsable du
département d de la politique des
produits de santé de la mutualité
française va vous évidemment vous donner
une série d'éléments importante qui
rendront à vos questions dans un premier
temps donc moi meme je sui vincent
figureau je suis responsable du
département des relations
institutionnelles nationales à la
fédération de la mutualité française
c'est à dire que je m'occupe des
relations que la fédération entretien
avec les pouvoirs publics français
je le signale parce que c'est quelque
chose que laure lechertier abordera il y
a également la fédération un département
europe qui a évidemment le même type de
rôle auprès des institutions européennes
et nous travaillons bien entendu en
étroite coopération
ces trois départements avec le
département que dirige laure lechertier
moi je voudrais juste puisque vous me
invité monsieur le rapporteur vous
donner quelques éléments importants sur
la mutualité française
vous savez que la mutualité française
est un acteur important de l'économie
sociale les mutuelles sont des sociétés
de personnes à but non lucratif et elles
sont basées sur un certain nombre de
principes comme la non lucrativité je
viens de le dire mais également l'inde
partage habilités des bénéfices puisque
les mutuelles sont des organismes qui ne
rémunère pas d'actionnaire c'est très
important de le souligner puisque c'est
quand même un très grand élément de
différenciation avec les autres acteurs
qui interviennent dans le marché de la
complémentaire santé notamment les
assureurs privés
les mutuelles sont également fondé sur
un certain nombre de grands principes
comme celui de solidarité et celui
également de non sélection en
particulier les mutuelles ne pratique
aucune sélection du risque soit quant à
l'âge quant à l'état de santé surtout
est également quant au niveau de revenu
les mutuelles ont un triple rôle je le
rappelle brièvement elles sont à la fois
financeurs puisque nous intervenons donc
en tant que complémentaires santé elles
sont offreurs de soins et elles sont
également un important facteur de
prévention et de promotion de la santé
je dirais même que c'est le premier
acteur dans ce troisième domaine
après les pouvoirs publics notamment
après la caisse nationale d'assurance
maladie
vous avez donc rappelé le poids en
quelque sorte dont 38 millions de
personnes couvertes par des mutuelles de
la mutualité française
ça vous donc vous dire que la mutualité
française est un acteur important dans
le nom de sanitaires et sociales et la
mutualité française comme elle l'a
toujours été depuis son origine est
force de propositions comme en témoigne
sa plate forme de proposition qui a été
élaborée en vue des élections à la fois
l'élection présidentielle et des
élections législatives qui dont la
campagne vient de démarrer
ces propositions ont notamment pour but
de renforcer le rôle du médecin traitant
de réduire la part des dépenses de santé
restant à charge est également
d'instaurer un droit réel à une
complémentaire santé solidaire c'est
donc des propositions qui sont centrés
beaucoup sur l'accès aux soins
c'est très bien qu'aujourd'hui le
problème majeur du système de santé
c'est la grande difficulté de l'accès
aux soins et toutes les barrières je ne
vais pas les détails et qui qui qui sont
posés contre un égal accès de soins pour
tous aux soins
donc en matière de santé un acteur
important et plus précisément en matière
de médicaments et plus généralement
également de produits de santé la
mutualité française est un acteur qui a
une légitimité à avoir un discours
public
je voudrais juste vous dire que
le médicament est la première dépense de
remboursement des mutuelles
aujourd'hui et si on additionne les
dépenses de médicaments et de
dispositifs médicaux
cela représente à peu près 42 % de la
dépense des mutuelles soit à peu près 5
milliards d'euros vous montre le poids
aussi que nous avons sur ce secteur
précis j'ajoute que je disais la
mutualité force de proposition en mars
2011 la mutualité française avait
proposé un plan médicaments qui avait
d'ailleurs été assez largement diffusées
notamment à sur un certain nombre de
parlementaires l'assemblée nationale
comme au sénat
je pense que vous madame la présidente
ainsi que monsieur le rapporteur aviez
dû recevoir ce document comme d'ailleurs
notre document de plateforme de
propositions que je tiens à votre
disposition dans le dossier que j'ai
laissée aux administrateurs qui sont là
mais je pense que avoir répondu à ce que
vous souhaitiez monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être lors ajouter quelque chose
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur donc laure lechertier
responsable des produits de santé à la
mutualité française
l'idée étant effectivement d'avoir un
positionnement stratégique à deux
niveaux c'est à dire à la fois européen
et national sur les produits de santé
positionnement stratégique en
développement une politique pour nos
mutuelles également et en proposant
aussi des actions très concrètes pour
nos adhérents à la fois s'ancrer sur le
médicament mais également les
dispositifs nick montrait bien mon
gendre est dans un premier temps donc
vous ne viviez
comment voyez les choses en matière
d'évolution au cours des 15 dernières
années de la place des dispositifs
médicaux en général et des dispositifs
médicaux implantables en particulier
puisque ce sont ceux-là ti qu'ils sont
ce qui en en priorité nous nous
intéresse
tout ça bien sûr dans les dépenses des
mutuelles en france et en europe
et est-ce que l'évolution des dépenses
varient tel en fonction des spécialités
observant une augmentation de la
population concernée par la poste de
dispositifs médicaux implantables à se
se recoupent tout seul je voulais sa
parole votre question porte
effectivement sur quel est le niveau de
financement des mutuelles sur les
dispositifs médicaux se trouve monsieur
le rapporteur que les mutuelles sont des
payeurs aveugles
que ce soit pour le médicament que pour
les dispositifs médicaux payeur aveugle
c'est à dire qu'à la différence du
régime obligatoire et de l'assurance
maladie
nous ne connaissons pas le code de ses
produits de santé c'est à dire que pour
le médicament nous n'avons pas accès au
fameux cote ces ip donc les mutuelles
savent qu'elles vont rembourser la
pharmacie à 65% ou à 30 % à 15 % mais
elle ne rompt pas à une analyse
détaillée des remboursements par
ailleurs pour les dispositifs médicaux
eh bien c'est exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire qu'elles n'ont elles ont
parfois des codes de regroupement mais
si vous voulez elles n'ont pas les codes
permettent une analyse fine de la
dépense
donc pour répondre à votre question nous
ne disposons pas de données en interne
qui viendrait donc de nos adhérents de
nos mutuelles puisqu'elle ne savent pas
ce qu'elles remboursent
et ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'extrêmement important l'accès aux
données
c'est à dire que c'est un enjeu majeur
pour les années à venir que les
mutuelles puissent avoir accès aux
données pour faire de la vraie gestion
du risque sur les produits de santé
donc quand on regarde pour vous répondre
à votre question on va combiner
plusieurs sources
au fond on va regarder les comptes
nationaux de la santé on va regarder
les étude de la drees on va regarder les
statistiques mensuelles que l'on a de la
cnam et on va pouvoir constater
justement que le marché des dispositifs
médicaux en tout cas remboursable est
présenté au remboursement est un marché
important et que la part des mutuelles a
presque doublé en 15 ans c'est à dire
qu'on est passé de 7 % de la dépense à
15% des dépenses de 515 millions d'euros
à 2 milliards d'euros donc en 2010
ça ce sont des chiffres issus des
comptes nationaux de la santé
donc on voit bien que c'est une part
croissante des dépenses pour les
mutuelles qui un fort dynamisme sur ce
poste là et après la difficulté c'est de
savoir à qui on impute le dynamisme sur
ce poste là puisque effectivement vous
avez plusieurs titres dans la lpp
plusieurs dispositifs qui sont concernés
et il ya une partie importante des
remboursements qui sont bien entendu
représenté par l'optique de dents que
vous ramenez excusez moi je suis né
juste mais nous avons également dans ses
remboursements
d'autres postes notamment le titre 1 et
le titre 2 sur lesquelles on voit un
taux d'évolution qui augmente d'année en
année
donc le titre 1 c'est tout ce qui est
pansements maintien à domicile le titre
2 c'est tout ce qui est orthez prothèses
et là on voit que c'est vraiment un
secteur très dynamique avec ce que nous
on appelle dans notre jargon un ticket
modérateur qui augmente l'équipe
progresse donc si vous voulez la
structure de financement au fond du
marché
il y a effectivement le régime
obligatoire qui va intervenir dans le
financement
mais les organismes complémentaires
d'assurance maladie joue un rôle
important dans le financement de ce
marché et dans les organismes
complémentaires d'assurance maladie ce
sont les mutuelles qui sont les premiers
financeurs
après votre question sur le niveau après
la 10 et sur le niveau européen
on n'a pas d'eau on a pas de d'abord
difficultés de superposer le modèle que
l'on connaît en france avec ce régime
sécurité sociale et assurance maladie
complémentaire à d'autres pays européens
et là dessus nous n'avons pas de données
précises et bien bon vous donc si je
commandais vous rembourser pour les
dispositifs médicaux implantables vous
remboursez l'acte en bourse et l'acte à
votre part dans le remboursement de
l'aqmi dans l'acte vous avez à la fois
l'acte d'implantation sur j call
notamment et le dispositif a pas de
séparation
alors si vous voulez là je vous ai
dressé un panorama du remboursement des
dispositifs médicaux en général en vous
disant qu'on n'était pas en capacité de
faire la distinction de l'art type de
dispositif médical sur les dieux les
dispositifs médicaux implantables
en général ils font partie de ghs et
dans ces cas là c'est au sein des
établissements que vous avez une
facturation avec une prise en charge qui
est souvent du 100% donc mais nous au
fond puisqu'on vous a expliqué on est à
la fois financeurs c'est à dire sur la
complémentaire santé donc là on va
intervenir mais on ergote également
offreurs de soins
et c'est bien dans nos établissements de
santé qu on est concerné par le
remboursement dans le cadre des ghs des
dispositifs médicaux implantables
mais nous n'avons pas de visibilité si
vous voulez on est légalement aussi je
suis désolé de ne pas pouvoir vous
donner plus de détails sur les
remboursements mais nous n'avons pas ces
remontées la d'information alors
justement je vous pose la question
suivante et qui est la suite logique que
pensez vous de la mise en place de
registre exhaustif à partir des bases de
données d'assurance maladie et des
hôpitaux afin d'automatiser la roto la
remontée d'informations vers les
pouvoirs publics
je pense que en tout cas pour la
mutualité française la traçabilité
d'un dispositif médical nous paraît
comme une exigence majeure donc un
élément qui est absolument
incontournable aussi bien en ville que
dans le circuit hospitalier donc en
identifiant bien les circuits de vente
en associant donc les officines les
points de vente les prestataires et puis
à l'hôpital effectivement une
traçabilité dans pour les dispositifs
financés en un trajet hs comme sur la
distance sus donc pour nous c'est une
exigence majeure
on souhaiterait également que ces
données de traçabilité soit rendu public
pour qu'on puisse connaître l'histoire
d'un dispositif médical donc de sa
fabrication à son utilisation finale et
on voit que en tout point de la chaîne
de distribution assurer une traçabilité
permet d'augmenter la sécurité sanitaire
permet également de faciliter les
retraits du marché quand on constate des
défaillances des dispositifs médicaux
mais pour cela il faudrait un système de
codification qu'ils soient harmonisés or
aujourd'hui la situation est que le
système de codification n'est pas
harmonisée puisque chaque établissement
va pratiquer sa propre codification donc
cette traçabilité
elle n'est pas assurée et le système de
codification pourrait être harmonisés un
niveau européen avec ce que l'on appelle
un identifiant unique et met justement
vendent pas identifié unique
nous n'aimons les préconisations à
l'heure pour enrichir le ep msi et le
codage des dispositifs quels sont les
préconisations
alors on avait bien sûr oui nous nous
notre préoccupation c'est d'harmoniser
d'avoir un langage commun sur justement
cette catégorie de produits de santé
après que l'on choisisse le pm et six
pages dirait que ça nécessiterait
investigation peu plus poussé
aujourd'hui le pm est si c'est un outil
qui est un outil de gestion des
établissements de soins qui a permis la
mise en place de la t2a c'est un outil
de planification de l'activité
après reste à savoir si on peut intégrer
au pn et si d'autres fonctionnalités
telles que la traçabilité des
dispositifs médicaux
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le père messier
peut-être pas arrivé à maturité
déjà dans ses autres fonctionnalités
pour y intégrer de nouvelles
fonctionnalités mais là dessus on n'a
pas une position arrêtée sur quel est
l'outil le plus pertinent pour assurer
cette traçabilité
j'attire seulement votre attention que
la question de la traçabilité d'un
dispositif médical c'est pas que
l'hôpital c'est que il faut aussi
décloisonner l'hôpital et la ville et
que le pm est si présente peut-être cet
inconvénient de ne pas assurer et
permettre la traçabilité en ville
vous aviez commencé sur intervenant
unique tout à l'heure
qu est-ce qu llano dire alors ce qu'on
peut vous dire là dessus c'est que nous
on est tout à fait favorable
un identifiant unique au niveau européen
ça nous semble
aller dans le bon sens pour améliorer
donc la traçabilité seulement européen
ou mondial
je pense qu'il faut faire étape par
étape
déjà au niveau européen ce sera une
bonne chose quand on voit si vous voulez
si on fait le parallèle avec le
médicament là on vient de répondre à une
consultation sur l'identifiant unique
pour le médicament justement qu'était
lancée par la commission européenne
on voit déjà les difficultés même sur le
médicament qui sont posés par cette mise
en place je pense que il faut avoir une
ambition peut-être un peu moindre mais
déjà essayons d'harmoniser le langage au
niveau européen
donc dans un souci de traçabilité dans
un souci donc d'identification des
dispositifs médicaux en cas d'effets
indésirables
ça permettra certainement une réduction
des erreurs médicales un peu plus de
documentation et surtout cet identifiant
unique permettra de faire des études
longitudinales oui mais épidémiologique
si vous voulez bon ton café un
identifiant unique ça nous sommes dans
une une économie et compression et
dispositif qui est mondialisée donc le
dispositif europe et aux états unis
comme les états unis pour avoir un
dispositif va nous enlever dispositif
européen
donc tant qu'à faire une une
identification unique ou un code-barres
qu'on voulait puisque c'est de ça dont
il s'agit
eh bien il faut le il faut le faire de
manière mondialisée autrement ça va
faire deux fois la même ou alors non
nous y menons nos dispositifs ne
pourront pas aller comme il le voudrait
hors de l'europe et
de la même manière les dispositifs hors
de l'europe pourrait difficilement bon
faudrait qu'il y ait d équivalent en
france donc t'as qu'à se lancer dans un
équipe n'identifiant unique
ne faut-il pas prendre le taureau par
les cornes comme l'a dit d'ailleurs aux
états unis et qui ont une volonté là
dessus et et faire quelque chose au
niveau mondial casio niveau mondial des
productions mondiales
oui je comprends tout à fait votre
approche sauf que j'y reviendrai très
longuement après les systèmes de mise
sur marché des dispositifs médicaux
entre l'europe et les états unis diffère
fortement
c'est à dire qu en europe vous avez une
offre en matière de dispositif médical
qui n'est pas du tout comparable à celle
des états unis qui est d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus importantes qu'aux états
unis
gj reviendrait tout à l'heure justement
donc moi je pense qu'il faut quand même
asus cas mais pas le même l'offre
le système et le site le système on peut
on peut en parler d'ores et déjà si vous
le souhaitez mais je pense qu'on devrait
s'inspirer largement du modèle américain
pour justement l'évaluation des
dispositifs médicaux
c'est intéressant allez-y développer
nous développons si vous voulez nous ce
qu'on a constaté c'est que au fond en
europe la mise sur le marché d'un
dispositif médical est extrêmement
facile
vous avez un cadre réglementaire qui est
très peu contraignant puisque il est
basé sur un certes un système de
certification qui repose sur ce fameux
marquage ce cette norme ceo fond elle
s'applique à tout objet industriel que
ce soit un grès le pain un jouet ou un
dispositif médical qui n'est quand même
pas un produit comme un autre puisque
c'est quand même un produit de santé et
donc
dans cette norme c'est eux on n'a pas
besoin de prouver l'efficacité du
dispositif médicaux mais juste une
conformité à des exigences essentielles
qui permettent bénéficier de ce fameux
label et ce fameux label est apposée
sous la responsabilité du fabriquant tu
donc puisque cette certification elle
est soit auto certifié pour certains
titres de la lpp soit se fait via des
organismes certifiés mais ça j'imagine
que vous connaissez parfaitement de
cette cette question là avec 63
organismes notifiés en europe qui ont
des exigences très variables qui vont au
fond faire un audit du système qualité
du fabricant et du dossier de conception
du fabricant qui parfois devrait enfin
devrais faire des audits suivi mais est
ce que ces audits suivi sont réalisés
voilà enfin il ya quand même un certain
nombre d'incertitudes qui pèsent sur ces
organismes de certification et on voit
bien que là il ya un transfert de
compétences qui s'est opérée d'un
régulateur vers un opérateur privé qui
est cet organisme certifié avec lequel
le fabricant a finalement une relation
contractuelle
donc c'est un contrat commercial qui est
passé et c'est cet organisme qui est
payé par le fabricant qui va délivrer
une auto et un marquage ce qui permet la
mission marché nous nous pensons que ce
système de certification et les
archaïques aujourd'hui le corps au
regard de ces dispositifs médicaux les
sons qu'elles ont préconisé à la place
et bien ce que nous on préconise
justement c'est
plusieurs choses c'est même une âme même
un transfert de responsabilités
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la
responsabilité elle ne doit pas reposer
sur le fabricant est l'organisme
notifiés dans la mission marché mais sur
l'autorité sanitaire qui devrait
justement délivrer une autorisation de
mise sur marché basée sur des études
cliniques qui soit méthodologiquement
irréprochable donc essentiellement plus
randomisée et l'a7 ce transfert de
responsabilité
nous souhaiterions que ce soit l' agence
européenne qui délivre cette fameuse
autorisation de mise en marché c'est à
dire que nous on vient renforcer sur l'
agence européenne
oulala wsop non l' agence européenne qui
fasse se contrôler ex ante et mais sur
des données et des études cliniques
c'est à dire qu'on a bien regardé un
l'évolution de la réglementation avec la
directive 2007 qui introduit si vous
voulez la notion de données cliniques
sauf que ces données cliniques au fond
ces preuves cliniques
elles peuvent très bien ne pas
correspondre au dispositif médical
étudiés c'est à dire ça peut être une
rue bourg l'abbé roger leaf numéro 3 oui
tout à fait ça peut être une simple
recherche biographique donc nous c'est
vraiment assujettir les dispositifs
médicaux à l'octroi d'une autorisation
de mission marché et ça nous sans ça
nous semble avoir du sens quand on
compare justement à la situation
américaine et le rapport du kce qu'est
le centre fédéral d'expertisé des soins
de santé belge qui est un excellent
rapport qui a été fait justement sur les
dispositifs médicaux implantables montre
bien et constate bien cette divergence
de méthode au fond sur les exigences à
l'entrée de la mission marché des
dispositifs médicaux avec aux états unis
des exigences d'études cliniques
randomisés en france donc deux seules
études de faisabilité de performance on
voit bien qu'on met en danger la
sécurité des patients mais priez comme
aux états unis circuits courts alors
comme le saint saury cas où
euh vous mettez donc ix où comme par
états unis vous aimez vous admettez que
les circuits courts puisque aux états
unis bon quand un produit est seulement
dérivés on considère qu'il a bon
d'accord et donc il suffit de passer par
un circuit court seulement de
certification là moi je vous parle de du
premarket approval qui est donnée par la
fcje est lui nommé watts vous avez les
deux vous avez le pré market et vous
avez laissé le premarket approval qui
doit prévaloir dans le système
d'autorisation
oui mais justement les états unis 90%
des dispositifs médicaux
c'est le syndicat et 10% sur le pré
marquer mais justement je pense que
c'est les 10% il faut généraliser ce
système dupré market qui permet de
sécuriser bien en amont les dispositifs
médicaux qui permet d'introduire de la
sélectivité et dans leur aplomb n'avez
pas peur que l'assurance a renchéri se
produit et que vous donc ça renchérit ce
vos remboursements
pas du tout nous ce qu'on voit comme
avantage est obligatoire
ce qu'on voit comme avant que vous avez
vous allez développer
bon vous allez allongée je me fais
l'avocat du diable un petit peu je suis
pas d'accord avec vous mais vous allez
allonger le circuit vous allez le faire
durer beaucoup plus longtemps donc
peut-être pouvoir passer à côté
d'innovation qui mériterait d'être le
plus rapidement possible mis sur le
marché est d'ailleurs le grand reproche
que font les sénateurs américains au au
système fin de la food and drug sais
c'est justement la lenteur par rapport
aux circuits européens je pense là je
suis
après vous reportez ne se trouvait pas
sur lequel je vous je vous pose des
questions puisque vous avez jeu ça nous
intéresse de savoir un peu votre news
nous notre occupation c'est pas de
savoir si ça va augmenter ou pas nos
dépenses en nous sommes pas dans cette
logique comptable là entre sonorités
d'abord nous nous ce qu'on veut c'est la
sécurité et l'innovation c'est à dire
qu'on rembourse au juste prix
les produits innovants aujourd'hui dans
le domaine des dispositifs médicaux on
voit pullulent et de nombreux mythes ou
un peu comme pour les médicaments qui
encombrent la lpp et qui n'ont pas fait
la preuve de leur bénéfice clinique qui
n'ont pas fait la preuve de leur
amélioration de la série sur les trois
sur les dispositifs bond important dans
la planification de 3 l'homme poussent
un peu non enfin moi je me régale et
léché des utilisateurs ne savent ne
s'amuse pas à utiliser des produits qui
ne sont pas fiables
parce que si les chirurgiens s'amuse à
poser dès samedi entamé très rapidement
avoir des problèmes
les récents scandales sanitaires sur les
sondes cardiaques monsieur rapporteur je
pense prouve le contraire qu' on est
moins dans la sonnerie adam et la
sampdoria tam et medtronic tes potes
fait d'accord les sondes cardiaques
d'affaires est excellent et qu'ils ont
et elles ont été mal posé
il y pas que leurs zones sont mauvais
ils disent qu'elles ont été mal posé
je ne crois pas l'afssaps a bien montré
qu'il y avait une défaillance des chocs
électriques qui étaient envoyés à
mauvais escient et du coup on voit bien
qu'on sait que ces sondes étaient bien
défaillante donc si vous voulez nous
pour reprendre mon propos sur au fond
nous ce qu'on veut c'est rétribués au
juste prix innovation bien longtemps et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on constate c'est que
on n'est pas dans une logique
d'innovation de rupture sur les
dispositifs médicaux on est dans une
logique d'innovation incrémentale
c'est-à-dire marginal qui pose quand
même la question de la valorisation est
ce qu'il faut valoriser l'innovation
incrémentale notre réponse est non parce
que c'est l'évolution naturelle du
marché
en revanche ce qu'on veut c'est une
vraie innovation et pour nous la
réglementation n'est pas un frein à
l'innovation au contraire c'est un
moteur et quand on regarde justement aux
états unis les états unis ce sont les
leaders incontestés sur le marché du
dispositif médical
donc ils ont déposé je crois que c'était
en 2006 à peu près dix mille brevets
quand on voit en france eh bien on a pas
en europe par dont on n'a pas autant de
brevets déposés on a une logique de
recherche et développement qui est bien
moins puisque je crois que c'est 5% du
chiffre d'affaires des fabricants qui
est investi dans la recherche
en fait en europe contre plus de 10% aux
etats-unis donc on voit bien que au fond
la réglementation dès lors qu'elle
renforçait les exigences permet au
contraire une innovation et d'aller vers
le haut et je veux juste aussi vous
attirer votre attention sur la has et la
cnedimts ces évaluations sur les
dispositifs médicaux aujourd'hui moi je
note que en 2010 c'est le rapport de la
chaise qui le dic est très enrichissant
sur 105 avis d'amélioration de service
attendue donc en prime wasp rixe
inscriptions sur les dispositifs
médicaux vous en avez 79 qui ont une
amélioration de service attendue de
niveau 5 c'est à dire pas d'amélioration
de service attendue c'est à dire que 75%
en prime un script
si on apporte pas de valeur sur fond de
concurrence on rentre dans les problèmes
de concurrence oui mais parce qu'on peut
en nouvelles choses qui n'a pas qui a
une sécurité équivalente mais pas
d'innovation supplémentaire de mettre
son produit sur le marché
ce c7 e7 une autre réflexion
oui mais c'est là vous avez des chiffres
sur ces normes je viens complet vous
souhaiteriez effectivement qui est
beaucoup plus de brûler ses lecteurs les
américains sont toujours plus forts que
nous sur le brevet parce que d'abord is
en dix ans une recherche qui est
beaucoup plus développée des crédits
monstrueux dans ce domaine et
et un nombre de laboratoires et
d'instituts de recherche bons qui sont
de très loin
ou oui il est important que les nôtres
donc si vous voulez et dans ce rapport
du kce vous avez un autre chiffre qui
est assez clairement c'est à dire que il
montre que sur les 8500 fabricants
européens vous en avait que 20 % qui ont
tenté d'investir le marché américain
pourquoi bien parce que justement ça ne
serait pas la barre beaucoup d'exigences
américaine vous avez beaucoup de petites
pme pmi dans ce domaine oui mais
justement il savait très bien que il ne
passerait pas la barre et d'ailleurs les
prothèses fixées elles ont bien été
refusée par les athlètes
la vérité c'est un autre sujet parce que
tout le monde va être encore l'agent pas
été tout à fait mais si vous voulez vous
avez quand même un certain nombre de
choses qui montrent que et bien la
réglementation quand elle est exigeante
justement elle favorise l'innovation et
elle n'est pas un frein à l'innovation
et je note aussi que les entreprises du
médicament en janvier 2012
ils ont fait un communiqué de presse en
disant il faut de la sécurité pour tous
les produits de santé et ils ont salué
la déclaration du ministre qui était de
demander une autorisation de mise sur le
marché pour les dispositifs médicaux
énorme leçon ils sont arrêtés au moins
10 en janvier ceux attachés d'ailleurs
si nous faisons cette mission c'est bien
pour ça parce que nos conclusions
iront dans ce sens nous pensons
effectivement qu'il ya beaucoup à faire
pour la sécurisation des dispositifs
médicaux dans toutes ses étapes je
souhaitais saône était surtout sur la
comparaison avec avec le système
américain mais je crois que bon ça mais
si vous voulez on l'a vu mais n'oublions
pas quand même vous dit vous avez
l'impression que mon l'innovation en
france dans l'innovation en france
existe je prenais comme exemple et valve
aortique qui sont implantable
directement de manière ingénieuse
donc c'est quand même quelque chose qui
est utilisé aujourd'hui de plus en plus
par les américains après qu'il l'ait
critiquée par un point détaillé son
critique et maintenant ils utilisent la
tour de bras donc je crois qu'il faut
pas mésestimer même avec des moyennes
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
bien moindre l'efficacité de
l'innovation france y en a quand même
pas mal
vous voudrez pour continuer juste si je
peux me permettre de jouer sur mon
propos n'est pas de dire qu'en france il
n'y a pas d'innovation
il ya moins d'innovation certainement
mon propos est de dire que il ya
aujourd'hui une contre-vérité qui
circulent sur le fait de dire que la
mise en place d'une année mais met un
frein à l'innovation contre-vérités qui
est relayée par la commission européenne
et moi je voudrais quand même vous
attirer votre attention sur l'europe
puisque on travaille beaucoup sur
l'europe et paula testory avec qui fait
partie de la dg sanco avait justement
accordé un interview au monde en mois de
janvier en disant notre philosophie avec
les états unis est fondamentalement
différente nous souhaitons un
renforcement ex post
nous voulons pas un contrôle externe et
on a bien compris
mais le rugby mais c'est vraiment la
philosophie de dire place au marché
place à la liberté du marché à la
compétitivité au détriment de la santé
des utilisateurs et 7 c'est une
constante que l'on va retrouver
également sur le médicament matière de
politique des produits de santé et nous
et si vous avez regardé la roadmap de la
commission européenne a que sortie
très clairement cette feuille de route
la commission indique bien qu'elle
s'oriente vers un renforcement ex post
très bien bon mais à ce sujet là vous
êtes tout à fait pour la multiplication
des études cliniques post inscriptions
alors sur lisez la matinée s'est pas
posé la question
je pars du principe que vous êtes
d'accord
absolument vous pensez qu'elle pourrait
améliorer le suivi des dispositifs
médicaux comme moi implantable parce que
c'est cela qu'on parle pas parler des
brosses à dents on pourra en parler mais
dans un autre cas qui devrait en assurer
le financement
parce que on rentre à la dans un domaine
où il faut savoir
bon c'est l'ailé les paroles c'est bien
les symboles encore mieux mais après il
faut financer alors qu'il devrait en
assurer le financement
faudrait-il envisagé de conditionner le
remboursement de certains dispositifs
médicaux à la réalisation de telles
études
alors tout d'abord pour répondre à votre
question bien évidemment on est pour le
développement des études post
inscriptions pour mesurer les bénéfices
du dispositif dans la vie réelle pour
voir également son efficience médico
économique
mais s'il faut pour nous qu'on servait
justement un équilibre c'est à dire que
c'est pas parce que on va renforcer les
études post a et même qu'on doit
s'exonérer d'études etc santé et
d'études cliniques pour la mise sur le
marché
au fond c'est un équilibre à préserver
entre ex ante et ex post
donc ça c'est rien ne vaut le suivi en
réel pas seulement un expertise tout à
fait que précéder tout ça c'est
intéressant savoir après dix ans que
deviennent protège tout à fait de
décrire les caractéristiques des
médecins utilisateurs des passions que
le recruteur et ses envies réelles
on est bien d'armes et qui paye
l'or qui fait qu'ils paient là dessus
nous on est on aura la même logique de
raisonnement que sur médicaments c'est à
dire que pour nous les études post
inscriptions devraient relever d'un
financement par la puissance publique
mais la question c'est on peut aussi
dégager des budgets pour conduire ses
études post inscriptions parce que pour
nous le fait qu'elle soit financée
qu'elle bénéficie d'un financement
public c'est le seul gage de leur
indépendance et il nous semble que pour
avoir des études objectives et qu'ils
soient les plus indépendantes possible
il faut qu' elle soit déconnecté d'un
financement industriel et ensuite vous
avez des mécanismes qui peuvent se
mettre en place pour dégager justement
des ressources pour faire ses études
j'ai réglages de l'indépendance et des
conflits d'intérêts type médiator
parce que là financement public n'est
pas toujours absolument un gage de
d'indépendance et oui on l'a vu avec le
médiator et qu'il n'y ait pas de conflit
d'intérêts dans les ceux qui ceux qui
jugent 2
de l'efficacité ou la non efficacité du
produit on peut pas on peut pas
systématiquement dire le financement
public est gage d'indépendance
à mon avis parce que on a tout un tas de
deux exemples qui nous montrent le
contraire
donc je veux bien mais en tout cas
seulement le financement public qui doit
intervenir ce soit je vous ferai redire
en priorisation pas en priorité oui ces
financements publics pas et qu'il n'y a
pas d avoir de participation de aucune
offre ne donne aucune autre structure
après il ya des phénomènes effectivement
pour encore une fois dégager les
ressources qui peuvent elles fabriquent
à il doit pas ils peuvent participer
financièrement si on est si on estime
que le la jugement et les sans conflit
d'intérêt
c'est toujours difficile en fait d'être
juge et partie quand on est fabricant il
pas juge et partie
il finance ont produit mais finance
finance l'évolution de son produit
l'expérience prouve que même quand vous
financez vous avez une vous allez avoir
une intervention sur le design de
l'étude sur la conception sur le déroulé
de l'étude et que par conséquent il ya
des billets qui peuvent être introduits
donc il faut essayer de tendre vers
l'indépendance à savoir plus non mais
écoutez on va opposer deux autres
questions - qui y est sur ce sujet s'est
développé sur wii
ces questions un peu différente sur le
sur l'esthétique donc s'il ya sur ce
sujet de grands développer s'il ya des
collègues qui veulent les commissaires
qui veulent poser des questions madame
la présidente
il est question merci madame la plus
simple moi je veux revenir sous pas une
du financement
qu'est ce qui empêche de faire un
financement par le producteur le
producteur de cette innovation en fin de
compte qu'ils soient faits en direction
d'un organisme qui serait monté qu'il
serait complètement dépendant vous dire
je vois pas du tout où est là où la
difficulté des cas quand vous dites il
faut un financement public
elle rapportera au 10 mai à peut-être
votre possibilité que on implique la
personne qui veut faire se présenter ses
innovations et puis son produit à
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit partie
prenante dans le financement même si
elle n'a pas à parra suis d'ailleurs la
loeb ça serait un essai de droit
d'entrée pour essayer de faire en sorte
que l finances en direction d'un
organisme indépendant du financement je
vois pas où est la difficulté sur les
six échappés de producteurs
effectivement marché ressorti mais enfin
quand même ça me semble important réside
disons que nous nous estimons que la
priorité c'est un financement public
pour garantir le maximum d'indépendance
ensuite la solution vous préconisez et
que au fond passe par une sorte de
plateforme qui serait alimenté
financièrement indépendante par le
fabricant un tel mécanisme peut
effectivement garantir un peu plus
d'indépendance
nous ce qu'on ne souhaite pas c'est que
les industriels financent les études et
décide de ses études c'est à dire de
leur conception du choix des indicateurs
du choix de la méthodologie
car là on sait très bien que ce finances
obligé de décider de toute la
méthodologie need
il ya un protocole qui peut-être à blick
par l'organisme indépendant par rapport
qui serait parfaitement d'ailleurs les i
flow a fait énormément distanti
financement de la réalisation de l'étude
pensent que c'est un critère essentiel
est par ailleurs il faut aussi exigé sur
ses études post 15 inscriptions ce que
j'ai oublié de vous dire la transparence
des données
c'est à dire que dans le monde du
dispositif médical on s'aperçoit que les
données ne sont pas rendus publics
c'est à dire que beaucoup d'études ne
sont pas publiés et vous avez beaucoup
d'articles du bmj qui montre que les
fabricants de dispositifs médicaux ne
publient pas leurs données
donc on ne sait pas c'est déjà un
phénomène qui existe sur le médicament
avec des études négatives qui ne sont
jamais publié mais qui est encore plus
fort sur dispositif médical donc toutes
les études post inscription doit faire
l'objet de transparence et d'une
publication des données
or dès lors qu'un financement par
l'industriel il peut on peut très bien
imaginer qu'ils exigent
et bien la non-publication justement des
données si elles ne sont pas favorables
à son produit
le financement indépendant permet
justement d'objectiver le rapport
bénéfice risque d'un dispositif médical
par exemple et de publier des données
négatives
le temps parce qu'il ya d'autres
questions sur les intérieurs avant de
passer aux interventions à visée
esthétique non sur les dm pouvait que
madame ne voulait pas mettre de frein à
l'innovation en augmentant les
procédures de sécurité mais en quoi
quels sont vos arguments pour dire que
ce n'est pas un frein à l'innovation
parce qu'il semblerait quand même que
sans son bord non toute ma démonstration
ajustements reposer sur le fait que
c'était au contraire un moteur
d'innovation 1 par la comparaison avec
la situation américaine et le nombre de
brevets déposés aux états unis et deux
au regard et bien d évaluation de la
chaise qui montre bien qu'aujourd'hui
une réglementation qui est très peu
contraignantes ne produit pas
d'innovation puisque 75% des produits
évalués par la hs non pas d'amélioration
du service attendu ou rendu avec des
élastiques se repose reproche à la f10
est justement d'être trop longue et etde
de faire que les produits innovants
viennent d'europe c'est qui même qui le
dit avant d'être mises en
en vente aux états unis oui ma dette à
fresnes une ruse
il faudrait vraiment définir ce qu'on
appelle l'innovation est ce que c'est
une nouveauté
est ce que c'est juste un changement de
couleur sur un dispositif médical ou est
ce que c'est une valeur thérapeutique
ajoutée pour le patient aujourd'hui on
n'est pas en capacité de le dire
puisqu'on n'a pas d'études cliniques qui
permette d'objectiver justement le
bénéfice pour le patient
madame carton oui ce film là je me dis
que c'est en fait la prédominance d'un
modèle économique qui qui qui prend le
pas par rapport à justement l'intérêt
médical primordial celui ce que donc
cette loi le voilà c'est comme ça qu'ils
sous tendu je pense que c'est la
conception européenne avec la directive
nouvelle approche qui était l'ouverture
d'un marché unique pour tous les
produits
en échange de d'exigence soi-disant
essentielles de sécurité mais qui
n'incluait pas des données cliniques
mais juste des études de performance et
de faisabilité c'est à dire on va
vérifier que la sonde elle délivre bien
le choc électrique ne va pas vérifié
qu'elles permettent bc l'arythmie du
patient sur plusieurs mois on va on va
passer aux interventions à visée
esthétique mais le modèle américain
n'est pas parfait non plus est sur la
corde sur la partie surtout sur la
partie innovations des oeufs ou ça vous
poser une seule question parce que le
reste a été développé
que vous inspire le développement du
tourisme en matière de chirurgie
esthétique avec vous c'est là la
question avez vous déjà eu à prendre en
charge des patients et ont souffert de
complications suite à de telles
interventions pratiquées à l'étranger
vous savez comment ça se passe dans ils
sont opérés ils sont pas hospitalisés à
l'étranger ils vont à l'hôtel et puis
trop cinq ou six jours à paris souvent
et puis avoir des complications
secondaire reste que si ces
complications surviennent en france très
souvent bon ils vont faire appel à ces
crises sociales et donc à leur mutuelle
donc je vous demandais ce que vous avez
vu comment on voulait détecter ceux là
et comment vous est ce que vous avez eu
des cas qui nous aurons pour lesquelles
on nous a demandé des prises en charge
encore une fois je puisque nous sommes
payeur aveugle puisque nous n'avons pas
accès à un certain nombre de données de
santé
nous ne sommes pas en mesure monsieur
rapporteur de répondre à sept kilos mais
vous demandez quand même aux gens si
quelle est la date de l'opération et et
qu'elle est bon chez le médecin si si si
à des complications médicales il ya
quand même des informations que vous
avez toutes ces informations restent
dans le dossier médical relève du secret
médical et ne sont pas transmises aux
mutuelles
donc nous nous n'avons pas de données
spécifiques à vous fournir sur ce point
là je le regrette mais et au sein de nos
établissements dont vous remboursez de
du laxisme étrangers quoi ah mais
peut-être mais vous savez on rembourse
pas de la rigueur sera le lot les
pratiques abusives on rembourse du
haurat mêmes médiator nous avons subi un
préjudice financier conséquent sur
médiator en remboursant médiator dans
des conditions aura et même bien sûr
mais nous simples meilleur aveugle donc
on peut pas faire cette transition du
risque justement nous sommes prêts
moi il ya quelque chose que j'arrive pas
bien comprendre comment se fait-il que
les mutuelles soient des payeurs
aveugles ça existe nulle part ce si ben
non mais là la mutuelle tight gas
sécurité sociale va vous savez le pays
tant ou d'été pour ces temps vous avez
des médecins conseils non ne peuvent
absolument pas si vous voulez c'est vrai
qu'on nous c'est vrai que c'est une de
nos revendications depuis maintenant
plus de 10 ans d'avoir accès aux données
de santé christian babusiaux lui même a
fait un rapport sur les complémentaires
santé en disant que nous étions tout à
fait légitime pour avoir accès aux
données de santé dès lors qu'on faisait
des expérimentations nous avons donc
fait des expérimentations de la buse ue
en démontrant qu'on était tout à fait en
capacité d'assurer la confidentialité
etc ce terrain des données mais
aujourd'hui la situation est que nous
n'avons toujours pas accès à ces données
est effectivement dans ces conditions là
on n'est pas à égalité avec l'assurance
maladie obligatoire et on peut pas faire
une politique de gestion du risque
alors que nous sommes financeurs et que
nous faisons souvent appel à la haute
finance justement des mutuelles dans le
cadre d'une assurance maladie qui a de
grosses difficultés
c'est clair
on a fait le tour aussi a plus d'autres
questions sur le rapporteur chers
collègues mais me reste à vous à vous
remercier merci au président voilà pour
cette audition si vous souhaitez la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit aujourd'hui henri guaino
ancien conseiller spécial de nicolas
sarkozy est candidat aux législatives
bonne soirée à tous